at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
pornhub just kidding this episode is
brought to you by four sig Matic which
is part of my morning routine also part
of my afternoon routine I have been in
lockdown for almost four weeks now and
routine saves me so there are a number
of ways that I use for sig Matic in the
mornings I regularly start with their
mushroom coffee instead of regular
coffee and it doesn't taste like
mushroom let me explain this first of
all zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do is add hot water
I use travel packets I've been to
probably a dozen countries with various
products from for sig Matic and their
mushroom coffee is top of the list
that's number one
I travel with it I recommend it I give
it to my employees I give it to house
guests so if you're one of the 60% of
Americans or more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one that is the
cognitive enhancement side easy on the
system side energizing side the next is
actually their chaga tea which tastes
delicious
it is decaf completely decaf and some
may recognise chaga it is nicknamed the
king of the mushrooms it is excellent
for immune system support so needless to
say I'm focused on that right now myself
and so I will often have that in the
afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends if you are
doing exercises I am on a daily basis to
keep myself sane cordyceps excellent for
endurance they have a whole slew of
options that you can check out every
single batch is third-party lab tested
for heavy metals allergen
all the bad stuff to make sure that what
gets into your hands is what you want to
put in your mouth and they always offer
a 100% money-back guarantee so you can
try it risk-free why not I have worked
out an exclusive offer with four sig
Matic because I've worked with them for
a very long time and I use their
products all the time on their
best-selling lion's mane coffee this is
just for you guys Tim Ferriss gel
listeners receive up to 25 percent off
the lion's mane coffee bundle check it
out plus you will also receive an
additional 20% off at checkout so to
claim this deal you must go to four
sigma tech comm slash Tim four sig Matic
that's fo you are SI g ma TI c dot-com
slash Tim this offer is only for you my
dear podcast listeners and is not
available on their regular website so go
to four sigma tech dot-com slashed him
and get yourself some awesome and
delicious lines main coffee and check
out their other stuff they got a whole
spectrum of products that I use on the
regular full discount applied at check
out this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs hiring can be hard really
hard and it can also be super super
expensive and painful if you get it
wrong I certainly have had that
experience firsthand multiple times and
I am NOT eager to repeat it so I tried
to do as much vetting as possible on the
front end and today with more qualified
candidates than ever you need a solution
you need a platform that helps you to
find the right people for your business
LinkedIn jobs does exactly that more
than 600 million users visit LinkedIn to
learn make connections gross
professionals and more than ever
discover new job opportunities in fact
overall LinkedIn members add 15 new
skills to their profiles and apply to
thirty five job posts every two seconds
that's a crazy stat LinkedIn does the
legwork to match you to your most
qualified candidates so that you can
focus on the hiring process getting the
person into your company who will
transform your business they make sure
your job post gets in front of the
people with the right hard skills and
soft skills to meet your
requirements they've made it as easy as
possible so check it out to get $50 off
of your first job post go to
linkedin.com slash to him again
that's linkedin.com slash Tim to get $50
off of your first job post terms and
conditions apply but check it out
linkedin.com
slash Tim well hello boys and girls this
is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show how do
meio teen Donnie - ah Nina and my guest
today is Laurie Gottlieb Lori is a
psychotherapist and author of The New
York Times bestseller maybe you should
talk to someone which is being adapted
as a television series by a Valon Coria
and the creators of the Emmy and Golden
Globe winning series the Americans which
I have watched many many hours of in
addition to her clinical practice she
writes the Atlantic's weekly dear
therapist advice column and contributes
regularly to the New York Times and many
other publications her recent TED talk
is one of the top ten most watched of
this year and she's a sought-after
expert in media such as The Today Show
Good Morning America the CBS Early Show
CNN and NPR's fresh air her new I heart
podcast dear therapists in the plural
produced by Katie Couric will premiere
this year so you can find her and learn
more at laurie Gottlieb calm that's lor
IG ot TL IE be calm you can also say
hello on social on twitter at laurie
Gottlieb won the number one on Instagram
Laurie Gottlieb underscore author and on
facebook at Gottlieb Lori so without
further ado please enjoy a wide-ranging
conversation with Laurie Gottlieb
Laurie welcome to the show well thank
you I'm thrilled to connect I've been
looking forward to connecting I'm sad we
couldn't do it in person but also
somewhat happy that we are both safe and
sound in our respective domiciles and
we're bringing quarantine Verte to the
masses as we mentioned before his record
and I thought we could start with a talk
of yours that you gave which you know
all honesty I have not yet had a chance
to listen to but someone on my staff
said you have to ask her about the story
she told at the moth in I believe it was
2014 can you describe what you ended up
sharing at the moth and why you decided
to share that sure so the story that I
told that the moth was about how I
became a parent and it was about the
process of being in my late 30s not
having found the person that I wanted to
spend my life with and knowing that I
wanted to be a mom and what I had to go
through in terms of finding a sperm
donor and kind of how surreal that was
to think about how do you choose the the
genetic material for this person who's
going to be your child and and what are
you even looking for and so it brought
up a lot of sort of existential
questions about you know nature versus
nurture and what this means for this
human being who would be this person who
would know who this you know maybe not
ever meet this donor but have limited
information about this person you know
it brought up so many sort of
philosophical and ethical questions and
so that's what I talked about how did
you decide to share that versus other
stories that you might share you you
have a life full of interesting stories
how did how did it come to pass that you
ended up on the stage sharing that at
the moth I think that that was probably
the most I would say it's the biggest
risk in life that I ever told
and it was also the best decision that I
ever made in my life
and so I think there were those two
pieces of it there was the making a
decision to do something with so much
uncertainty and then knowing in that
deep place of knowing that we all have
that it was absolutely a decision I had
to make that I could not go through life
and not have done what I did and so and
knowing that there were all kinds of
risks and all kinds of downsides and
still going through and saying but I
know I know in every cell of my body
that this is the right thing to do and
by right thing to do you're referring to
having a child not getting on the stage
at the moth I'm referring to having the
child yeah getting on the stage was you
know it was I will say something about
getting on the stage I will say that I
really believe that so many of us are
carrying around really fascinating
stories that we don't think are that
fascinating we think our lives are
pretty ordinary but as a therapist I can
tell you that the most extraordinary
stories come out of people that are
grounded in the ordinary and so maybe
there was something extraordinary about
yes I'm gonna go use a sperm donor to
have a child back then it was very
unusual now it's much more common but I
also think that that sharing our stories
we realize that we are all so similar
that we all have even if the story the
content of the story is completely
foreign to somebody that the emotions
the feelings the questions those are so
universal and so when I got up on that
stage and I told the story the audience
reaction was profound to me because I
felt so unique in my experience and kind
of so different for what I had done and
so many people related to different
aspects of the story
and and it helped them to feel more
connected as well which I think is a
huge service to not just the audience in
front of the stage but of course the
wider audience
who then has a greater feeling of
connectedness or less a feeling of
isolation and hearing these stories
could you elaborate on a term I came
across a number of times in preparing
for this conversation which is the
hierarchy of pain what is the hierarchy
of pain what does that refer to so
that's something that I think is really
crucial when we talk about suffering and
struggle that so many times we tend to
not pay attention to what we're feeling
because we immediately want to minimize
it because we feel like well I have a
roof over my head and food on the table
so you know the sadness that I'm
experiencing this anxiety this this
grief
whatever it is insomnia whatever it is
we think well you know really it's
nothing I'll just I'll just power
through it stiff upper lip but we don't
do that with our physical health right
so something feels off in our bodies
we're gonna go get it checked out so
you're having like something you feel
like a little something in your chest
you know you might go to the
cardiologist and say like what's going
on before you have a massive heart
attack but what we do with our emotional
health is we feel like it's not worth
pursuing it's not worth talking about
because other people have such bigger
problems so I'm not gonna do anything
about it and then what happens is people
land in my office when they're in a
crisis it's like the equivalent of an
emotional heart attack and at that point
first of all they've suffered
unnecessarily for a long time and also
it's harder to treat because now they're
in a crisis and so I feel like you know
there isn't a hierarchy of pain pain as
pain and suffering as suffering and so
that's why and remember when I was
training in fact as an intern I I was
like how will I go from somebody who for
instance has cancer right to somebody
who's like you know the babysitter's
dealing for me or you know why do I
always have to initiate sex or you know
one of those kinds of kinds of issues
and what I found is that underneath the
content are the same kind of universal
questions how do I trust what does it
feel like to be betrayed
how do I deal with uncertainty and when
we don't talk about these things our
behaviors our feelings come out in
behaviors they come out in different
ways they come out in an inability to
sit still in a short-tempered nests in
procrastination in self-sabotage in what
my colleague likes to call of the
internet she says it's the most
effective short-term non prescription
painkiller out there so you just sit
there and you're like numbing your
feelings by just scrolling through
things going down the internet rabbit
hole you know they'll come out those
feelings won't go away
and so I think that we really need to
get rid of this idea of this hierarchy
of pain that you have to meet a certain
threshold of pain for it to be dealt
with or taken seriously now as we're
absorbing that and thinking about pain
our individual pain our collective pain
collective anxiety personal anxiety etc
sometimes those pains are self evident
sometimes the sources or contributing
causes to those pains are more obvious
than at other times and this is where
self assessment but also therapy can
enter the picture and be very valuable I
would imagine
and you've spoken before at least as I'm
reading this was from NPR but idiot
compassion versus wise compassion and
I'm just going to read something really
quickly here idiot passion is where you
want to make someone feel better and so
you don't necessarily tell them truth
wise compassion is where you really hold
up the mirror to them in a compassionate
way but you also deliver a very
important truth bomb and my question
about this is one related to real-world
examples because at least in this piece
which is from last year I'm not sure if
you still go to Wendell but how does how
does your therapist to the person you
have seen deliver that truth to you how
does one do that skillfully and more
specifically how have your therapists
done it skillfully right so that's
something that that both my therapist
did with me and that I do with my
patients and I think a lot of it has to
do
timing and dosage so that and that's why
it's hard for friends and friends often
end up falling into that idiot
compassion bucket because a friend will
come to you and say oh my god you know
this this my partner did this and you
know and we immediately take our friend
side we immediately say yeah that's
terrible
or my boss did this or I didn't get this
promotion and we say yeah they don't see
your talent whatever it is and in the
moment that's not the time to deliver
wise compassion because they're smarting
from from the injury but I think that
that you can ask certain questions like
you know what you're trying to get at is
you know if a fight breaks out and every
bar you're going to maybe it's you so
you know we see that with our friends
all the time like they keep ending up in
the same situation different people
different characters but similar
situations and so maybe they're the
common denominator and so you can ask
questions about well what do you think
happened and and and you know our
instinct as humans we all do this is to
blame something out there and the reason
that it's so much easier to say that the
problem is out there is because if we
say that there's something going on with
us we have so much shame around that and
shame is the reason that we have trouble
taking responsibility for our role in a
story so if your role in the story is
you're not getting the promotion because
you actually don't get along well with
that coworker right the one who did get
promoted or your role in the story is
the reason people keep leaving you is
because you're very needy and you're
very suspicious or you don't trust or
whatever it is you know there's certain
behaviors that you have certain patterns
we don't want to look at that because we
feel like if we acknowledge that there
is something we're doing that that's a
criticism that that says something is
wrong with us and it doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means
you're just not aware of a behavior and
so there's a big difference between
something is like wrong with you as a
person or something is problematic about
a behavior that you're engaging in could
you give another example or examples of
approaches or language that can be used
to sort of lead a horse to water
that's not do insulting but in the sense
that I have blind spots we all have
blind spots and sometimes you need
friends to point them out to you but
it's it's easy if it's delivered in the
wrong way or at the wrong time to become
defensive so what are some tools that
can be used to sort of open the door to
that type of self-reflection I think the
first thing is that people need to feel
understood before they're going to be
able to self-reflect and so when I
talked about timing and dosage what I
meant was that first you need to let the
person know that you understand the
story that they're telling from their
perspective and I keep using the word
story because everybody's coming in with
a story and we're all to some extent
unreliable narrators and so you don't
have to agree with their version of the
story but you have to understand how
they feel about the story and they have
to feel felt they have to feel that you
understand them even if you might not
agree with all of the details of you
know how they're telling the story and
once they feel understood and then they
feel accepted for how they feel so you
don't try to talk them out of their
feelings with logic so many of us try to
do that especially with our partners
right we try to talk them out of their
feelings
well you shouldn't feel that way because
X and a lot of us experience that is
kids right so we don't know how to
access their feelings so a lot of us as
kids we might have said like you know
I'm sad and you're very well-meaning
parent might have said like don't be sad
hey look a balloon right hey let's go to
Disneyland or you know when you were
young you might've said like I'm angry
and they would have sent like really
you're so sensitive you know those kinds
of things so I think that when somebody
is telling you something and you're
thinking in your head wow they're making
a big deal about this or they shouldn't
feel this way because here's this other
perspective on it there's no shoulds
about how you feel that's just actually
how they feel and so if you can have
come
passion for how they feel if you can
imagine it and even have empathy they
will be more able then to their their
shame will kind of diminish and they
will feel more able than to self-reflect
and that's when you can start asking
questions like what do you think the
other person in this if they were if
they were telling the story what do you
think they might be saying what do you
think their version would be right can
you can you try to imagine you know kind
of you broaden the story for these
people
and once they start to broaden the story
they allow other perspectives to come
into the narrative and then they start
rewriting their own narrative a little
bit there there's some movement there
and it doesn't happen all at once this
is this isn't one conversation this is
many conversations and if you're if this
is in the context of say your
significant other and a lot of people
are going to be spending more time in
close quarters for at least the next few
weeks and I would imagine that there
will be some strife some disagreement
and I would love to hear what type of
language might be used in those
circumstances where you're not referring
to a third party so as an example of
what not to do I have a friend who's his
version of apologizing is always
something along the following lines well
I'm so sorry that you took that so
personally yeah the headbutt disguised
his apology which doesn't lend itself to
much conflict resolution so what types
of approaches or language might be
useful when things are escalating
between two people yeah so I see a lot
of couples in my practice and one of the
things that I see so often is something
like somebody's trying to be heard by
the other person
and that person says something like you
never listen to me and I always say to
the person who says you never listen to
me to the partner how well do you listen
to him or her right because when we're
screaming you never listened to me you
usually that person who says that is not
a very good listener and so I think that
when you are hearing something when
someone's trying to tell you something
are you truly listening or are you are
you constructing your defense as they're
talking are you thinking about how you
are going to defend yourself against
their perceived complaint because then
you're not hearing them at all and also
part of listening isn't just hearing the
content of what they're trying to tell
you but are you reading their body
language are you reading their facial
expressions this isn't something that
just happens in a therapy room this is
how we need to be able to communicate
better with one another and it doesn't
take a lot of effort it's it's more of a
reframing of what it means to have a
conversation with someone thank you for
that and if we zoom out just to define
some terms that will no doubt be using
more how do you think of therapy and I
suppose on one hand therapy is a broad
term like medicine so it may not be a
good question but if people listening
have tried certain types of therapy and
it's worked or it hasn't worked or
perhaps if never engaged in what is
called certainly in the West or Western
psychotherapy therapy what is therapy
and what are some common myths about it
so I think that therapy can be defined
you know people will define therapy in a
lot of different ways I can tell you how
I define therapy perfect so I define
therapy as something taking place in the
same room in the same space one-on-one
on a consistent basis so usually that's
weekly and and it's it's a process of
really trying to understand oneself
better in the sense of understanding
what are this person's blind spots how
does one navigate through the world more
smoothly what are some of the ways that
we're carrying things from the past and
we don't realize it it's like it's like
wearing clothes that don't fit anymore
that somehow we're walking around with
this these clothes that don't fit and
they're affecting the way that we
manifest in the world the way we present
the way we behave so you know and I
think this part of getting to know
yourself is it's also getting to unknown
that refers to the old clothing that I
was just talking about that that part of
getting to know yourself is to let go of
these ideas that you've been carrying
around about yourself that just aren't
accurate for something you just said
which I love so much and that is getting
to unknown that's that's a very helpful
way to phrase it I don't mean to
interrupt but I've never heard anyone
say that before and I just wanted to
mention it in part so that I remember it
so sorry sorry to interrupt
but if we all have our stories right as
you said and we're very unreliable
narrators and we our recollection is
often recreation and we're attached to
those stories so getting to unknown the
way to put it
thank you well that's right I mean I
think that we carry around these stories
like you know I'm unlovable or you know
whatever it might be that people have
these stories that they think about that
define them and they think that a lot of
what therapy is is to really examine the
accuracy of those stories and and
whether they really are serving them at
this point in their lives so getting to
unknowns to let go of these very
limiting stories that you've been
carrying around so that you can live
your life and not the story that you've
been telling yourself about your life so
many of us are walking around living
some story that we're telling ourselves
about our lives that doesn't reflect
reality at all I don't know if you're
willing to delve into the personal a bit
on this and feel no pressure but could
you tell the story about I suppose
that's kind of not intended to be ironic
use but to share story or describe one
or more of the ways that that have been
important for you personally to get to
unknown are there any particular stories
that you've had that we're disabling and
so
way that you've had to work on and have
worked on well I think one of the
stories that it's the story that I
opened with in the book which is that my
the person that I was planning to marry
my boyfriend at the time told me one
night that all of a sudden he said you
know I've decided that I don't think I
can live with a kid under my roof for
the next ten years and that kid at the
time was my eight-year-old who had not
been hiding in the closet the whole time
we were dating so my my version of this
story was you know what my friend said
the idiot compassion right he's a
sociopath or he's a jerk or who does
that and and the story that I brought to
my therapist was I was so attached to
that story that this was all him and I
think that the through the process of
going through therapy it became very
clear that I had a role in this story
and the the role that I was taking on
was was like this happened to me and I
didn't see it and I was blindsided by
this and it was a very old story for me
it was like a story from my childhood it
was a story that you know this this idea
that you know things were happening to
me and I had very little control over
that and and and it bled into this adult
relationship and so it became very clear
in my therapy that there were clues that
he was not a hit person there were Clues
all along we weren't talking about it so
you know but we were both responsible
for him for not telling me and me for
ignoring the times that it did come up
and not really pursuing it because in
some ways even if our stories are not
stories we want to live we somehow
orchestrate our lives to to keep the
storyline going so someone might have
that story of you know I'm a victim and
they don't want to be a victim but what
happens is they orchestrate things so
that they will be a victim in those
stories why do you know why wise I agree
with you that that happens why does that
happen it happens because because we
cling to the familiar so that feels like
home
so even if home was unpleasant or
miserable at least it's something that
we know if we go and we say oh wait what
if I what if I'm not what if I'm not a
victim what if I have what if I'm not
trapped right my therapist told me about
this this was so life-changing for me it
was a cartoon he told me about at one
point I was talking about all the ways
that you know I was trapped and you know
there was no way out of any of these
situations that I was talking about and
he said you remind me of this cartoon
and it's of a prisoner shaking the bars
desperately trying to get out but on the
right on the left the bars are open the
prisoners free right right but so many
of us don't walk around those parts so
the question is why don't we why don't
we walk around the bars and the reason
is because we want to be free but with
freedom comes responsibility and so if
we walk around those bars we're not the
victim anymore and now we have to take
responsibility for our choices now we
have to be proactive and make things
happen for ourselves now we can't say
the world is limiting me the world is
holding me back I can't have this dream
of mine because you know something out
there is preventing me from having it
now it's on us so that was a story when
I had to unknown I self I had to unknown
a part of myself that tended to go into
that place of everything out there is
limiting me and you know life is unfair
so I had to I had to really examine that
story and I didn't even know that I was
still carrying around that story mmm
thank you for sharing that and what
distinguishes in your mind a good
therapist from a great therapist what
are what are some of the differences
that you would observe if you reflect
back on the people you consider great
therapists what do they have in common
that separates them from good therapists
yeah I think Wendell the therapist that
I write about in the book is a great
therapist and they think what makes him
a great therapist is that he's so
himself in the room he brings his full
humanity into the room he's not
I think there's a stereotype of
therapists as being very much like a
tabula rasa and it's not that Wendell
was disclosing things about his life I
knew very little about his life until of
course the night that I Google stalked
him but you know I it wasn't we didn't
talk about him in the room
but but he as a human it was clear that
he was the same person in the therapy
room that he might be out in the world
if there was not a persona that he was
bringing into the room and so he was
very spontaneous in the room and I think
it's almost like like as a musician
right if you are a pianist let's say and
you have to learn your scales and they
have to be very precise and you have to
know them so well and you just drill
them and drill them and drill them
that's what we get in graduate school we
drill the precision of being a therapist
but we don't drill the art right the art
is something that's mud that comes out
from experience and so I think that you
know once you know those skills then you
can improvise but you can't really
improvise as well if you don't have the
foundational stuff down so the same
thing I think with Wendell was he had
the foundational stuff down but man
could he improvise how did that manifest
what would what did good improv or what
does it or can it look like well one of
the things he did that really surprised
me was you know at one point I was sort
of going on and on about the breakup and
you know and I and and I was looking on
social media and I was looking at you
know this imaginary wonderful life that
my ex was now having and and he just he
stood up
Wendell stood up and he came over and he
kicked me and not even hurt me just so
it was like I was I was like what was
that and he said well you seem to really
enjoy suffering and what he mad was he
explained that there's a difference
between pain and suffering we all
experience pain at different points in
our lives but we sometimes don't have to
suffer
so much that sometimes we are the cause
of our suffering and I was the cause of
my suffering by spending all of this
emotional real estate on what was going
on with my ex-boyfriends life right and
it was just it was creating all this
suffering I you know I didn't have to be
doing that there were other ways that I
could manage my grief that I could move
through my grief that didn't involve
kind of retraumatization so let's let's
segue this is feels like a perfect
window to segue into I believe what
would still be one of your favorite
Maxim's that I highlighted for myself
and that is insight is the booby prize
of therapy can you explain what that
means I love that too because I think a
lot of people believe that when they
come to therapy they're going for
insight why do I do this why is it like
this why do I keep getting into these
arguments with my partner why am I stuck
in my job you know the why and and you
can have all the insight in the world
but if you don't actually make changes
out in the world the insight is useless
so I like to say that when you come to
therapy you have to be both vulnerable
and accountable the vulnerability is you
have to actually let me see you you
can't do the whole like look over here
look over here look over here and try to
distract me with all these different
stories because if I can't see the truth
of who you are I won't be able to
connect with you I won't be able to help
you connect with yourself and we won't
be able to get that insight so that's
the insight piece but then there's the
accountable part right which is okay now
that you understand why these arguments
keep escalating in your marriage right
somebody might come back the next week
and they'll say yeah so I got in this
fight with my wife and I understand now
exactly I understood it as it was
happening exactly why why this was
happening and I said well did you do
something different well no but I
understood why it was happening right
it's like that's not helpful I mean it's
it's helpful to some extent
but what you need to do then is you need
to do something different because of
this insight so maybe you understand now
that when you react in a certain way to
what your wife is saying that that's
going to escalate things so just because
you understand the why and what it
brings up in you what are you going to
do differently now so once people start
changing their behavior that's when they
start to see real change in their lives
how did you for instance take the pain
is unavoidable suffering is optional
just to paraphrase how did you take that
insight after Wendell kicked you if you
did and translate it into behavior
modification yeah well the first
behavior was I stopped you know the
whole online searching for the
ex-boyfriend because it just wasn't
serving me I think also changing my
behavior in terms of making up these
stories about you know if he posted like
a salad in a restaurant I'd be like well
how can he even eat he didn't miss me at
all you know like these these I mean you
go to a very young place I think when we
experienced the end of a relationship no
matter how old we are
we often go to this very primal place
because as a species we need to connect
and I think that when we experience sort
of the shock of disconnection it can
really be discombobulating so there was
a lot of really focusing more on
grieving then on what was going on with
his life could I sit with my grief could
I sit with the sadness could I sit with
the loss and that was so much more
helpful for me even though it was a lot
more painful yeah I can empathize yes
it's it is one of I feel the least for
me one of my main challenges has been
identifying what I am unwilling to feel
right historically and trying to
practice allowing those things and being
kind to myself when I am experiencing
them instead of feeding a living [ __ ]
out of myself for
opening the door to any of those
feelings it's working progress I'm so
glad you said the thing about beating
the [ __ ] out of yourself because I think
so many of us sell flagellate and we
think that if we sell flagellate that
will help us feel better it's it's very
paradoxical but you know if I kick the
[ __ ] out of myself that I'm gonna whip
myself into shape and I'm gonna make
these changes self-flagellation never
leads to long-term change
self-flagellation might sort of make you
do something in the moment but it won't
last the way that you make long-term
change is by having self compassion and
people are really afraid to allow
themselves to feel compassion for
themselves because they think that then
they won't be accountable they think
that if I am kind to myself I will not
make these changes I won't be motivated
and the exact opposite is true that the
nicer you are to yourself the kinder you
are to yourself the more motivated you
will be to change you're having a hard
time with that woman oh well I I'm doing
much better
I am trending in the right direction
I'll say that it's still a task on
repeat for me and there are ways that I
do practice that typically have meal
times in a grace silent grace of sorts
which is not for any religious purpose
but because it conveniently piggybacks
on a habit that is going to happen two
to three times per day every day so it's
a useful cue in that sense but it is
work in progress for sure I view it as
one of my most important tasks at the
top of the Cascade in a sense I'd love
to ask you about helping people in
therapy one on one one on two whatever
it might be versus your dear therapist
column and I'm asking in part because
you have a large audience and the the
dynamic is very at least for me has been
very different could you speak to that
and then I'll probably have a bunch of
questions sure so I think in both cases
in the therapy room and in the dear
therapist column and then also in the
new podcast that we're doing which is
gonna be dear therapists and it's a
different dynamic because in the therapy
room in all of these I should say
somebody is coming in with their story
and what you want to do is you want to
help them to edit their story and so in
the therapy room you have week to week
you can go through the editing process
with somebody you help them to see
something so a lot of times people in in
all of these you know whether it's the
the podcast the column the therapy room
people will come in and usually there's
there's some problem with someone out in
the world right so and you know and and
by the way there's lots of difficult
people in the world when I was training
a supervisor said to us before
diagnosing someone with depression make
sure they're not surrounded by [ __ ]
so yes you know there's a reality to to
what they're saying there are they're
difficult people they're having a
difficult situation I understand that
but what is the role what is the role in
that and so in the therapy room if I am
helping them to kind of edit that story
I have a lot of time to do that I don't
mean that we want to keep people there
for years I mean that I have from week
to week if I forget to say something or
I can let something marinate because I
have I can control kind of how much I
release it once I can go back the next
week if I forgot to say something I can
make a note and go back to it if they're
being if they're not really open to
something that week I can try to come in
a different way another time or even in
the room in that session with the column
you get one shot you can't really tell
what the reaction is so you can't sort
of say okay I'm saying this here's how
they're reacting to it and now I'm gonna
you know I was a competitive chess
player when I was younger and I use a
lot of that in therapy with which is you
know I make this move they make this
move I have to adjust my move in the
column I can't adjust my move so I think
what I'm trying to do in the column is
I'm trying to not only answer the
question for that person but
trying to answer it forever to answer
something for every person who's reading
it which is how is this gonna relate to
the way they think about the world so
it's a it's a more general answer it's
not like here's specifically what you
should say to your mother-in-law even
though it's it's more about here's a
different way to think about this and
here's something that I see going on
that maybe is more Universal and and
this I think applies to your situation
and this will help you come to a place
of knowing what you should do how do you
think about if at all the risks of
public advice in the sense
I'll speak personally having written on
a blog for more than a decade now
thousands of posts large audience there
are topics that I have drafted and then
not published or published and then
removed because I've asked myself the
question what happens if 1% get this
wrong like 1% don't read the disclaimer
or 1% don't read the second half of the
article what are the worst things that
could happen and I scare myself and I
think rightly so in some instances and
it could just be a difference in subject
matter but do you ever worry about
writing to the masses not that you
shouldn't I think there's tremendous
value in doing so but do you think about
that you know I want to go back to the
kindness for a second and answering this
question because I think that one of the
things that happens is we have these
voices in our heads that try to talk us
out of things that often that the most
authentic place in us is the quiet voice
is the voice that it's like hey listen
to me and then we get these louder
voices and say oh but what if this what
if the audience doesn't like this what
if somebody doesn't like this what if I
just please somebody and I think that we
need to give more air to that quieter
voice that says this is important to me
and I'm gonna say it and if people don't
like it or if I made a mistake that's
okay and so I think you know even in my
book where I'm very very
kind of like let it rip you know and
there are some people who would say wow
that's really inappropriate but it was
something that I felt like I had to tell
that story in that way and so when I
write my column
sometimes I'll give advice that that I
know some people will take issue with or
there have been lots of times where I've
said something in a column you know
you're on a deadline every week so you
don't have a lot of time to think about
it you you write what you write in the
space of your your production schedule
and maybe later I might think oh wow I
wish I had said this or readers will
definitely tell you right they'll say
you know oh wow that therapist is awful
she didn't say this and I think people
can be so critical in that way I think
it's I I really want to hear from
readers what I didn't get right I learn
and grow that way I would like them to
say it in a kind way but but I think
that I don't beat myself up if I miss
something if I didn't say something if I
made an outright error where I feel like
wow that was really misguided I'll say
something on social media like yeah I
should have said that that's a really
good point and it's like what I say I
always say this about about why I
decided to write so much about myself
like in my journalism at my book and you
know in all kinds of places I will just
close things because I don't want to be
the expert up on high I want to use my
expertise to help people but I always
say that my greatest credential is that
I'm a card-carrying member of the human
race and if I can't model for people
what is like to make a mistake what is
like to be kind to yourself when you
make a mistake what is like when people
are attacking you and how not to get
into like that negative space with that
you know somebody today I'll tell you
something happened today on Twitter I
had posted something I said something
like if I if I can't touch my face soon
I think I might need to go to therapy
because of coronavirus and it was just
this this thing that I posted that I
didn't think much about but I posted it
because I think like we're all trying to
cope with this and this person wrote bat
wrote on there not funny right and it
would I wrote to them was that some
people use humor to cope with really
horrible
and it might not be this person who does
that but that sometimes we need to you
know it's kind of both and that this is
a horrible situation and sometimes our
souls need to breathe and so I think
that it's a and a lot of people sort of
responded to that and I think that you
know it made me think though you know
was that insensitive and and what does
that mean and it made me really do a
little bit of soul-searching about you
know how do we use humor when we're
trying to cope with something horrible
so I welcome all of that I don't
overthink what I'm writing or I don't
overthink what I should say this I think
very very much about what I'm writing
because I want to put something out
there that's valuable to people but I
don't overthink what the reaction is
gonna be I don't I don't hide because
I'm worried that I might offend somebody
because by the way you always will right
yeah ten percent are always gonna find a
way to take it personally and I suppose
just for clarity because I probably
didn't convey clearly that I'm on one
hand completely agree I'm gonna
paraphrase here but I think was Mae West
who said those who are easily shocked
should be shocked more often so I agree
with that and then on the other hand I'm
mostly referring to safety
considerations because I'm somewhat
appalled by the reckless I'm not talking
about you I'm talking about some other
people with large audiences I've seen
giving what I would consider reckless
say medical advice regarding
prescription medication and so on
related to coronavirus where someone who
can parse that effectively might be able
to derive more value than risk but a lot
of people will not right so it's it's
it's more on on that end that I try to
measure twice and cut once but I would
love to love to segue here for a second
to discuss that perhaps the the tools
that you use to identify the spot blind
spots now it sounds like an oxymoron but
they're there if the therapists job on
in some respect is to hold up a mirror
and have people notice their blind spots
how might you suggest to people
listening if they can't afford a
therapist
or for whatever reason just don't have
the ability to get into a therapy room
are there any approaches they can take
to better spot their own blind spots or
have friends help them to identify them
yeah that's such a good question I think
that the therapist has the advantage of
having the vantage point of not living
that person's life so it's like we
ourselves are so zoomed in we're so
close but a therapist is looking at you
from the outside you know there's oom
doubt right they can see the the broader
perspective it's so hard for all of us
to see ourselves clearly and so I think
that one way that people can identify
that something might be up is if
something keeps happening over and over
you know it's not coincidence I think
that so many times we want to attribute
something not working to something
external and so I think that it's really
important to say like what are some of
these things that are going on that are
that are keeping me stock that are not
working for me and and then to really
kind of kind of try to see the
similarities what are some of the
patterns another thing is that I think
that work most revealed in the context
of our relationships with others and if
you see something happening over and
over in your relate the way you relate
to others in the way that others relate
to you that's something to look at also
but I don't want to be I'm not
proselytizing therapy but I do think
that it's very hard to self-examine
without having another objective person
to almost get a really good second
opinion on your life from and that's
what I kind of think therapy is in a lot
of ways it's like a really good second
opinion on what might be going on yeah
it'd be really helpful at some point and
I would love to try to assemble this but
sets of questions that people could use
to enable their friends to prompt them
in ways that help them to identify blind
spots right because I do that
in say the case of editing writing if I
if I have a smart friend I can give them
a set of questions like which 10% would
you keep if you could only keep 10% what
10% would you cut if you could only cut
10% etc etc I can enable them to take on
the role of good proofreader even if
they're not ostensibly trained for that
so that's that's a homework assignment
for me I suppose
well you there's asking the question
then there's being there's the openness
to hearing what they have to say I also
think you really have to choose your
audience for that one you know I I think
that so many times if you ask those
questions the person that you're asking
will have a personal agenda so you know
if you said if you really wanted to know
well what do you find most challenging
about me that person will name all the
things that they want to change that
will make their lives better right so
it's like they have an agenda a parapet
doesn't have that agenda a therapist can
see in the room by the way the
relationship in the room is a very very
it's full of energy it's full of
richness it's it's it's it's a relation
it's a unique relationship right because
it doesn't exist outside of the room
even though you might think about your
therapist during the week and your
therapist might think about you but what
happens in the therapy room is a
microcosm of how you relate to the other
people outside of the therapy room the
other people in your life so so when I'm
interacting with someone in the therapy
room I don't need to ask what other
people find challenging about them I'm
experiencing it I'm seeing it I'm
finding them challenging because they're
doing with me exactly what they do with
people out there and so if you want to
come up with your questions you know
outside like somebody in your in your
personal life asking those questions I
think that that's really hard because
often that person will have their own
agenda they will have their own things
that they want to change that will you
know that for their own reasons that not
necessarily about your own well-being
and anyone less
about that which is that true sometimes
the person that you're with doesn't want
you to change because they want to
maintain sort of the homeostasis in the
in the family unit so if you're kind of
the person who's struggling they get to
be the healthy sane person and if you
become the healthy sane person then all
of a sudden they have to look at what's
not working in their own lives this
happens a lot like when somebody says
like you know what I'm gonna leave my
this job that I feel stuck in and I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna try to do this
other thing this dream that I've always
had and the other person is like oh
that's so risky oh don't do that
that's so risky you know or why would
you do that or that's unrealistic or
they try to sabotage it in a way that's
much more subtle it's because all of a
sudden you're upsetting the homeostasis
in the system maybe they were the
successful one
you know maybe they liked it that way or
somebody decides they're gonna get
healthy and they're gonna lose weight or
they're gonna go to the gym and they're
like oh you're no fun anymore you don't
want to come out with me so so many
times we we aren't doing this
consciously but sometimes we feel
threatened when other people get healthy
when other people are doing things that
maybe we wish we could do and this is I
say this about Envy a lot right when
people are envious they're so afraid to
feel their Envy and I'm like feel your
Envy use your Envy because you want to
follow your envy it tells you what you
want
don't use your envy to sabotage someone
to to say mean things about that person
use your envy as a catalyst to figure
out what you can change in your own life
that's very good advice and I've seen
what you describe and is often
subconsciously in partners where one
will begin to change and the other one
will act like the crabs in the crab
bucket sort of pulling the one crab down
that was trying to get over the edge at
very common I've seen this through my
audience over the years with weight loss
like you mentioned with entrepreneurship
quitting a job starting something as you
mentioned not to say that all concerns
will be unfounded and self centered with
some ulterior motive but that is
extremely extremely common let me try a
question on you if I might and this is
this is gonna be the first time I've
ever asked this question on a podcast
but Tyler Cowen recently asked me this
and I it opened up a whole portion of
the conversations so this is just along
the this is an attempt to to sort of dig
and see where this goes might go nowhere
how do you think we you and I are most
similar or most different or both I
don't know you well enough to really
answer that well right just based on
based on the little that you know or
based on this conversation based on any
of it I think we're both very interested
in making change in the world and I
think that you know we're both we're
both very I was a proactive about doing
that I think from what little I know
about you know you that you've disclosed
and publicly I think that that we both
have gone through because some kind of
evolution of defining success
differently that I think that we both
you know we both kind of were very you
know we grew up in a way where we worked
really hard at school and we succeeded
academically and we went to you know
prestigious schools and I think when we
got to those schools both of us started
to realize wait a minute this is not the
secret to happiness and I think both of
us struggled when we were in those
schools I know I did and I read about
the ways that you did so I think that it
made us question a lot of what we had
worked for and how we had worked for it
and I think that both of us put our
energy that you know that kind of energy
that we put into our academic lives I
think that we put it into our
professional lives but I think that our
goals are very different than they were
when we were like trying to get the
highest a in the class
mm-hmm I agree what did your struggles
look like I've written about as you
mentioned for those people who want to
see just how dark the darkness can be
you can look up some practical thoughts
on suicide and my name and you'll find
stories about that period how did you
struggle what did your struggles look
like I think that my struggles were
about working really hard to achieve
something achieving it and then going
now what you know really questioning
sort of the meaning and the purpose and
it took me a long time I think that you
know it wasn't until you know I switched
around a lot in terms of my career and
they think that that was because I I
kept searching for that meaning and
purpose in the right way and so you know
when I when I was in college I started
doing these internships in the
entertainment world because I was really
interested in telling good stories and I
was really interested in the human
condition I felt like at the time this
was before TV became what it is now I
was like that's movies right so I had
always been really just profoundly
changed by certain movies what were your
majors at the time or what were you
focused on in school well I was a French
literature major and I liked that of
course you know the existentialist right
so you know you think about like what
was I reading at the time it was really
depressing but but I was really
interested in culture and literature and
story and so I think everything when I
look at it in retrospect everything that
I did was about story in the human
condition whether I was working in the
entertainment business I think you know
that that I ended up you know working in
film and then I moved over and I did
network television and I worked at NBC
and that was the year that friends in ER
premiered so it was like the beginning
of this this era in must-see TV on
Thursday nights on NBC and and ER was a
really unique show because it was so
realistic
it told these very rich human stories
and and it was it was sort of like it
felt like a documentary in a lot of ways
and at least in the beginning and and I
used to hang out a lot in the ER with
the consultant on the show who was an ER
doc and certain point he said to me you
know I think you like it better here
than you like your day job and it was
one of those things where you know I had
worked so hard in school and that I
worked so hard at my job and I worked so
hard to get the job at NBC and he was
like you should go to medical school
that's that's where your passion is I
see it in you and I was like I'm not
leaving that job but I did because I
wanted to I wanted to be immersed in the
real stories right so I went to medical
school and then when I went to medical
school I went up to Stanford where it
was the beginning of the it was actually
the end of the first dot-com boom right
before the first bust so this is like
1999-2000 and when I was there it was
like everybody was talking about this
newfangled thing called managed care and
my whole idea was I'm going to be the
the family doctor the person who guides
people through their lives and I'm gonna
have these rich relationships with my
patients and it just wasn't looking like
that was where the medical world was
headed and so I started writing when I
was up there and I ended up then leaving
to become a journalist because I thought
I want to delve into people's stories
and I want to help them tell their
stories and so I did long form
journalism what I still do and I love
and and it was it was later when I had a
baby that I was you know working from
home as long form journalist oh and I
was I needed adults to talk to I needed
like adults
I needed a conversation that UPS guy
would come and he would literally would
detain him and I would say how about
those diapers and do you have kids and
he would like back away to his big brown
truck and eventually he started just
very quietly placing the packages on my
doorstep so that he did not have to
interact with me and I thought okay like
I was really you know it's really hard
it was like
you know you have this new baby you love
this new baby I wanted this baby so
badly and yet I was like I need I need
to be out again it's that that
connection and story that when you're
doing it remotely it's not the same and
so I called up the Dean at at Stanford
where I had been at Medical School and I
said maybe I should come back and do
psychiatry and she said well first of
all you're welcome to come back but if
you become a psychiatrist you're gonna
go through all this training and you're
probably going to be prescribing
medication in 15-minute intervals and
yes you can do talk therapy but why
don't you get a graduate degree in
clinical psychology and you can do the
work you want to do and not do residency
and you know try to do all this with
with a toddler and so it was it was
amazing it was it was the best advice it
was one of those aha really good advice
from somebody who's taking the time to
think it through that's great right and
and it seems really obvious in
retrospect but at the time you know
you're just like how do I do this and so
and so that's what I did and I feel like
I went from in journalism I went from
telling people stories to as a therapist
helping people to change their stories I
feel like a lot of what I do as a
therapist is a lot of that editing work
that I would do when I was interviewing
people when I was writing their stories
really asking a lot of the same kinds of
questions so definitely I feel like when
you ask like how are we the same and how
are we different I feel like what
happened was both of us found meaning
and purpose we both feel like we were
doing something that is helping other
people and I feel like that's what I'm
doing and all these kind of different
pieces of my career and you also have
kind of a hybrid career and I think
you're doing that in the different
pieces of your career too thank you I'm
doing giving it a good old college try I
think like like most humans we're still
searching yeah we're still asking we're
so curious we're still discovering when
you look back at your chapter
Changez say from entertainment to med
school or med school to journalism which
decision or transition was the hardest
in other words I'd love to hear more
about some of the detail of one of the
harder jumps when it was it where any of
these decisions that you agonized over
for days or weeks or months or was it
just a flash of insight and decisive
action which of these which of these was
was difficult for you if any leaving the
entertainment business wasn't difficult
for me because I was so clear that there
was something deeper that I wanted to
pursue not that movies and television
can't be incredibly profound but I think
there was something that was more
personally resonant for me about working
with actual people out there and which
sort of foreshadows of course what I do
as a therapist but was what was hard
about that change was that everybody
thought I was crazy that everybody said
how do you leave you know how do you
leave this this place that you're in in
your career how do you leave that and
just go to medical school
I think what was harder was leaving
medical school because I had already
made this switch I went to I was up at
medical school and you know it takes a
lot by the way you know you have to take
all the other classes to take the MCAT
and you take the MCAT and you have to
you know for meet all the requirements
and I was again not a science major
although I was very kind of math and
science II as a person you know I was
like on the math team and you know those
kinds of things but I wasn't I didn't I
was very much taking humanities courses
in college and so and literature and so
I think that doing everything that it
took to get to medical school getting
into a medical school being at a medical
school and then saying you know what I'm
gonna go be a freelance journalist not
just not just any medical school either
right I mean Ural and Palme drive or you
buy with beautiful Stanford so I can
imagine that that also has a decent bit
of waiting in some people's minds also
financially III think that you know what
we're so worried about talking about
money in our culture everybody I think
it's a very real thing and I think
people need to talk more about it
because you know there I was you know I
already paid for two years in medical
school and I had loans and and you know
now I'm gonna go be a freelance
journalist you know who does that and
they think what it was is what I was
talking about earlier is that voice that
quiet voice where everybody else is
saying just finished Medical School just
get just get the degree and then figure
out what you want to do you know just
just tough it out for two more years and
it was like I don't like life is short
and I was very aware of that
even back then that that you know this
is a theme that that kind of is you see
all over my work which is this theme of
why thinking about death makes us
happier right which is which is I don't
mean to Welling I mean just haven't just
acknowledging it just acknowledging that
life has a hundred percent mortality
rate and most of us don't know how or
when we're going to die and so I think
that even though I was in my 30s then
which sounds young it's not you know
it's like why why should I spend those
next two years in medical school when I
know that I want to go right when that's
what I want to do is I want to go tell
other people's stories I want to go to
this work that's where the fire in my
belly was and so I just followed the
fire in my belly and I said I'm gonna
have to make sacrifices I'm gonna have
to make a lot of financial sacrifices
and I'm gonna have to write a lot to
make enough money to support myself and
to pay off my medical school loans etc
now I had some money saved up from
Hollywood but not enough to sustain me
so you know these are the choices that
people make and it was again a choice
where people said you know I really
suggest you do this that or the other
thing and I really listened to myself
and and what I wanted to do and and
becoming a therapist was the easy choice
you know in the last of the changes but
I feel like every single thing that I
did was really just looking at story in
the human condition from a different
perspective so I don't feel like I had
four different careers I feel like I had
one career and I'm just kind of
experiencing them from different ways of
getting in sure that makes sense to me I
mean if you look at the nonlinear career
progression and in hindsight each of
those chapters has added something to
the quiver that you use today
it would seem right looking looking at
it from that lens how did you develop
this awareness of death when did that
when did that develop how did that
develop was it reading all these French
philosophers and writers or was it
something else no it was medical school
it was medical school and I did a
rotation a pediatric oncology rotation
and I it sounds brutal yeah I actually
thought that's what I wanted to do and I
didn't even have you know wasn't a
parent then and it was so I opening it
it just it it got it like hit me on my
core in a way that I think it matured me
in a lot of ways it really made me
appreciate so much about life and living
and and all of the opportunities that
each of us has every day if we're
healthy you know I think so many times
we think about all the things are going
wrong in our lives and you know people
will say hashtag first world problems
and all of that and going back to the
hierarchy of pain but I think that we
take for granted our health and so that
has ever since medical school I've been
acutely aware of what a gift it is to be
able to do the things that we want to do
because we're healthy enough to do them
and you know in the book I write about
health crisis that I had that I sits on
going where I have some kind of
autoimmune situation going on and for a
very long time
the doctors um you know some of them
dismissed me as sort of you know what I
call I go back and I trace the history
of sort of the wandering uterus and
hysteria on the way that sometimes
certainly male doctors especially kind
of dismissed me as oh it's anxiety or oh
you need to sleep better when that
wasn't the case at all and so I I think
now especially that you know I I do
experience symptoms from you know just
having a compromised immune system that
I'm even more acutely aware of of making
sure that I appreciate everything that I
can do you know with the health that I
do have what a what a I suppose
testament at least in your case to the
price of admission for medical school
possibly being worth it in just putting
you on that rotation so that you have
this vivid imagery and autobiographical
experience that keeps you aware of how
valuable your health is that is so easy
to take for granted if you haven't seen
firsthand those who are robbed of health
or who will soon die and that's in a way
I'm worth worth the MCAT and the prep
and all that put together not to say the
people should go ethical school just for
that but in your case very valuable and
I would say some people you know there
was something that really shocked me
when I was in medical school which is we
were doing our dissection unit so you
have these cadavers and you're learning
you know anatomy and physiology and and
one of that you have to figure out why
your cadaver died why that person died
so that they don't tell you you have to
like figured out by what you notice when
you're dissecting that person and one of
them had died of lung cancer and it
became very clear that the person had
been a smoker and you could even see
like nicotine stains in the person's
nails and the the person one of the
medical students who was working on that
cadaver would go outside at the breaks
and smoke Wow like
was a smoker and that didn't stop him
from smoking so I think there's this
idea you know some people have this idea
that they're you know immortal was that
you know they're not they're not
vulnerable to the vicissitudes of you
know just being a living organism and
that that was so striking to me and that
image too from medical school stays with
me like the idea of how strong denial
can be and as a therapist when I see
people in denial I always think of that
that fellow student of mine who would
just you know be dissecting this person
who died of lung cancer then go outside
and smoke well that's how that's how
much sometimes denial serves off denial
is a way of staving off these really
uncomfortable feelings that we don't
want to acknowledge and my job as a
therapist is to really get under that
denial and to be able to help somebody
to see that dealing with the feelings is
gonna be a lot easier than staying in
tonight I know this is gonna sound like
a terrible question because it's okay
I'm sure it could be 15 a 15 volume set
of books but how do you do that there's
denial everywhere I've experienced
denial most people have experienced some
form of denial how do you help someone
get past denial or what are some of the
what are what are some of the approaches
or tools that you might use well I think
it's it's a way of helping to
communicate to them but that our fear of
our feelings is often scarier than the
feelings themselves right and so I help
them to feel a little bit at a time and
I help to contain them so that they'll
feel something and they realize it's not
going to kill them and then they are
kind of like oh that that like I gave
mice you know I gave myself some room to
breathe and then I think that they you
know that that helps them to say okay I
can feel a little bit more and I could
feel a little bit more and also just
that what they what they discover went
the more that they feel is that feelings
are like whether
systems they blow in they blow out it's
not like because you feel something the
storm is gonna stay there indefinitely
the sun's gonna come in and then it's
gonna get windy and then maybe you know
a little rain will blow in again and so
you know it moves you know it's it's
again what I was talking about earlier
that both and that you can feel
something that is hard that is difficult
right that causes you pain and you can
also have joy in in the book there's
somebody who's dealing with a really
really tragic death and and the person
was saying that like after the child
died after his child died that he was
with his other child and and they were
and they laughed you know they were like
they laughed and they were like playing
a game and they laughed and he was like
how could I laugh my child just died a
week ago and he like felt like the worst
person in the world for feeling that but
it's like that's the weather system
doesn't mean that you aren't in
excruciating pain but we can also laugh
both aunt yeah both end it's taking a
taking a second to think about that that
I mean I could see yeah that's it's wild
I mean I've been thinking about pain and
the experience of pain and the
metabolizing a pain and the persistence
for some people of various types of
physical or psycho emotional pain and
what we are about to go through in the
sense that we're recording this on
Friday 13th March 13th and we're about
to have I think some very challenging
weeks ahead of us that'll probably
exacerbate or magnify some of the
tendencies that we all have that we
might not notice as much when we are not
under duress so it's something that I'm
thinking about a lot how are you
yourself we don't have to we don't have
to speak to you know the virus and the
disease and so on itself and get into
kovat 19 but for your own sore
psychological health how are you
thinking about practices for yourself
over the next handful of weeks or months
if you have
yeah you know so I will speak about
Kovac just because it's right here in
front of us so my son is now doing
remote learning his school has closed
and one of the things that I noticed is
how happy I am to see him that you know
every time I walk by and I see him it's
like wow you know in a few years he's
going to be in college and I'm not going
to get to see him and I'm just sort of
relishing the time that I have with him
so that I'm not just watching the news
every second I'm not just focusing on
here's this update here's this other
update I think that that can be really
anxiety provoking and and we need to be
anxious right and and it's and there's
all this tragedy happening all around us
and it could happen to us too but I
think that it's important that people
find ways to you know it's there's a lot
of Viktor Frankl in my book you know the
right and so you know one of the things
he said very famously was that you know
there's a I'm gonna paraphrase here but
there's a freedom that nobody can take
away for there's one thing that nobody
can take away from us and that's the
freedom to choose our attitude in any
given situation and he was talking about
being in a concentration camp that he
was saying even in the midst of this
horror of the concentration camp I get
to choose where my mind goes like only I
get to choose that and I I think it's
very relevant to what's going on with
kovat in the sense of we can have a
dance party in our living room because
we happen to be home right which doesn't
mean that we don't feel the horror of
everything else is going on and the
anxiety and-and-and-and don't feel for
all the families that are losing their
loved ones and don't feel for all the
people who are in I see yous right now
and don't feel the terror of what's
gonna happen when you know many more of
us get it and there are no beds
and all of that is very real you know
you and I were supposed to be talking in
person right now at South by Southwest
and here we are doing our remote and
thank God that we are that week that we
were able to connect with people which i
think is really important in this time
is using technology to connect with
people when you can't physically be in
the same space definitely and you know
I've been recognizing more and more so
since I've been in self-quarantine
effectively for the last two weeks
because I've pre-existing pulmonary
issues and I'm taking extra precaution
that fortunately I have my girlfriend
and my dog here so I'm not isolated and
I can see the challenges that would be
magnified certainly if that were the
case but just seeing other faces like we
used video for a few minutes before we
went to audio only to record this
episode using FaceTime when possible to
see human faces of friends of loved ones
and so on that in and of itself I've
found to really on some evolutionary
level or evolved basis to be very
helpful to for staving off feelings of
isolation just something that simple and
fortunately simple given the technology
that most of us if you're listening to
this podcast chances are you have
technology that would allow that with it
yeah that's true and I think that that
in therapy you know a lot of people will
say well can I do like a phone session
or can I do like text Arup even I don't
even know how that would go but
apparently people do that and I I don't
even like doing Skype therapy a
colleague of mine said that Skype
therapy is like doing therapy with a
condom on because you know it's like
there's something about the energy in
the room where you're both you can hear
the other person breathe there's the
same kind of smells and sounds in the
room and there's something about the
just the
the physicality of being in the same
space and so often in our lives when we
get together with people we have like a
phone on the table or you know what text
comes in and we're not actually spending
you know an hour face-to-face with no
distractions and I think especially now
in this time where we have to isolate
yeah the next best thing would be to
FaceTime or Skype or do something where
you can see someone's face but when
we're not in this time I really really
recommend that people go spend time in
person right after after we're not
worried about coronavirus it's so
important to physically be in the same
space with somebody and not be
interrupted by your device we all will
survive just fine if you spend an hour
with somebody and and not check your
phone agree it very much agreed I have
just just a handful of additional
questions for you one is you mentioned
Viktor Frankl are there books that you
have reread many times or a handful of
times or given often as gifts besides
any besides your own are there books
that come to mind for you that you have
particularly reread or gifted oh yeah I
love giving books as gifts they're
they're my favorite gift to receive and
I love to give them because I feel like
I'm giving an experience to somebody
it's not just an object but it's an it's
a an experience that they will have as
they read something so books to me are
the best gift and one book that I give a
lot is a book called the tennis partner
by Abraham for Daisy I don't know if you
know who he is he's a he's a doctor
he's now at Stanford but he he was in El
Paso for a long time he wrote cutting
for stone which I think got made into a
movie but this book was about when it's
about his relation we never really hear
about male friendship
and this is a book about his
relationship when he was getting out of
his marriage and he was supervising
interns in El Paso and an intern came to
him who had an addiction and this person
it was the interns last chance to you
know like not get kicked out of an
internship program and get sober and
it's about their friendship and they
really bonded on the tennis court of all
things
they're both serious tennis players and
it's an incredibly moving story about
you know the limits of what we can do to
help another person the attachment that
we can feel to a complete stranger the
ways that other people are mirrors for
us and help us to see our own issues in
a different way
it's just a beautiful beautiful
meditation on not just male friendship
but I think just human connection so I
give that one a lot to by the way to men
to women people of all ages it's a book
that that people really respond to
beautiful thank you for that I have just
written that down and we'll be checking
on that myself and you have an
incredible number of projects it seems
your book maybe you should talk to
someone who's being adapted as
television series you have a new podcast
as you mentioned dear therapists which
is being produced by Katie Couric why
these two projects and I'm sure you have
more in the hopper but how did you end
up deciding to dedicate your energies to
these two projects so the television
series was a way I think of bringing
emotional health and normalizing it to
just a greater a greater audience you
know I mean the book has been very
widely read but I think that TV reaches
people in a way that really nothing else
can I mean podcasts of course your
podcast look at what your thought cast
is doing
it's rating better than many television
shows I guess but but I feel like also
just seeing seeing other people's
dilemma seeing other people's struggle
see other people kind of the
ridiculousness of the human condition
you know we're all ridiculous and we
take ourselves so seriously and I think
that when you can see yourself through
the lens of another person's story is
kind of like this Tim it's like if I
said to you Tim you do this all the time
you're like this you'd be like no I
don't I'm not like that or you might
feel offended even if you recognized it
and you said yeah I kind of am but you
might feel like it was critical but if
you see somebody else doing the very
thing that you do you're like oh yeah I
do that right it's so much easier to see
ourselves through other people and what
they do as mirrors for us and so I think
at the television show and I'm really
excited about is it's not a show about
therapists it's a show about people who
happen to be therapists and there's a
distinction and the distinction is one
would be like oh let's do all that sort
of stereotypical stuff that people think
about therapy which is you know yeah you
know every every single trope that
you've seen on television about
therapists or we can do something about
human beings and this happens to be
their career and so I'm really excited
and I think the guys from the Americans
who you know I think write with a lot of
nuance and you know I think they're
they're so smart and they're also able
to infuse it with that kind of real
authentic humor not jokey humor but
humor of like yes I see myself in that
and that's funny
so I'm really excited to kind of bring
that to more people when I think with
the podcast it's the same thing it's
about you know one thing that we're
doing on the podcast is I have a co-host
who's guy winch guy and I have both done
TED Talks and and we met through sort of
the TED world and he is a
psychotherapist in New York and we
really want people to it's one thing in
our in the column to be able to say you
know let me let me examine your
situation on paper but it's another
thing to just be able to have a
conversation with someone and and and
hear what they're saying and ask them
those questions and so not
only are we going to have people come on
and talk about you know like what's
their dilemma but then guy and I are
gonna have a private conversation which
the listener will hear but the the
person who wrote the letter will not
which is how the therapist talked about
this how do we think about their problem
and then how do we go back to them and
kind of what you were asking earlier how
do you say to them the thing that you
want to say in a way that they'll be
able to hear it which might be different
from the way guy and I discussed it with
each other so you get to hear that
difference and then we give them our
suggestions and then what's interesting
is in the column you never get to hear
what happened I get to hear because
sometimes people will write to me and
say I tried your advice and here's what
happened but the reader doesn't get to
hear in our podcast we bring them on a
few weeks later and they tell us what
happened that's excellent and I think
that's so interesting because people can
learn so much from that we really want
people to learn from this podcast we
want them to see something about their
own lives and from this podcast and so
you know what worked and what didn't and
why I think that's always so helpful and
guy winch is one of the most amazing
names I've ever heard in my life
that is a great TED talks I'll check it
out where can people learn more about
both the television show the podcast and
so on and if they want to find either or
both of them of course of your website
Laurie Gottlieb comm which I'll link to
in the show notes as well are there
other places they should look I will be
posting about these on social media so
they can always follow me on twitter at
laurie Gottlieb one they can follow me
on Instagram which I'm still trying to
figure out how to use Laurie Gottlieb
underscore author I'm on facebook at
Gottlieb Lory
you know I heart will be actually the
promos are going up right now for the
podcast just as we're getting our inbox
full of letters and we've been taping a
few of the episodes and the TV show you
know I'm sure you will hear about
through normal media channels well
that's that's when you know you have the
right partners if you say don't worry
you'll hear about it
and what a pleasure this conversation
has been on the socials are you most
fluent with use of Twitter or is is
another option best if people want to
wave and say hello Twitter is probably
the one that my as a not tech-savvy
person that's the one that's easiest for
me to use but I'm on all of them they
can say hi to me on any of them right
and that is at Laurie Gottlieb one with
the number one at the end of your full
name this has been such a pleasure I'm
really happy that we were able to carve
out the time and that you're willing to
carve out the time to have this
conversation I have pages and pages and
notes and I also appreciate you being so
open to discuss the personal stories I
really I really really appreciate it
this has been also therapeutic for me
just to just to have the conversation oh
thank you so much Tim I'm such a fan of
your blog your podcast you know I really
admire how much you've been willing to
share with everybody and I was so
excited to have this conversation with
you so thank you for having me on my
pleasure entirely hopefully not the last
conversation that we have and for
everybody listening I will link to
everything we've talked about in the
show notes including all of the new
projects that Laurie is working on as
well as the website Laurie Gottlieb comm
in the show notes which can always be
found at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast and until next time thanks for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday and that
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs
hiring can be hard really hard and it
can also be super super expensive and
painful if you get it wrong I certainly
have had that experience firsthand
multiple times and I am NOT eager to
repeat it so I tried to do as much
vetting as possible on the front end and
today with more qualified candidates
than ever you need a solution you need a
platform that helps you to find the
right people for your business LinkedIn
jobs does exactly that more than 600
million users visit LinkedIn to learn
make connections grows professionals and
more than ever discover new job
opportunities in fact overall LinkedIn
members add 15 new skills to their
profiles and apply to 35 job posts every
two seconds that's a crazy stat LinkedIn
does the legwork to match you to your
most qualified candidates so that you
can focus on the hiring process getting
the person into your company who will
transform your business they make sure
your job post gets in front of the
people with the right hard skills and
soft skills to meet your requirements
they've made it as easy as possible so
check it out to get $50 off of your
first job post go to linkedin.com slash
to him again that's linkedin.com slash
Tim to get $50 off of your first job
post terms and conditions apply check it
out
linkedin.com slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by pornhub just kidding
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma deck which is part of my morning
routine also part of my afternoon
routine I have been in
down for almost four weeks now and
routine saves so there are a number of
ways that I use for sig Matic in the
mornings I regularly start with their
mushroom coffee instead of regular
coffee and it doesn't taste like Russia
let me explain this first of all zero
sugar zero calories half the caffeine of
regular coffee it's easy on my stomach
tastes amazing and all you have to do is
add hot water I use travel packets I've
been to probably a dozen countries with
various products from or Sigma Dec and
their mushroom coffee is top of the list
that's number one
I travel with it I recommend it I give
it to my employees I give it to house
guests so if you're one of the 60% of
Americans or more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one that is the
cognitive enhancement side easy on the
system side energizing side the next is
actually their chaga tea which he's
delicious it is decaf completely decaf
and some may recognize chaga it is
nicknamed the king of the mushrooms it
is excellent for immune system support
so needless to say I have focused on
that right now myself and so I will
often have that in the afternoons they
make all sorts of different mushroom
blends if you aren't doing exercises I
am on a daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out every single batch is
third-party lab tested for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff to make sure
that what gets into your hands is what
you want to put in your mouth and they
always offer a 100% money-back guarantee
so you can try it risk-free why not I
have worked out an exclusive offer with
four sig Matic because I've worked with
them for a very long time and I use
their products all the time on their
best-selling lion's mane coffee this is
just for you guys Tim Ferriss gel
listeners receive up to 25% off the
lion's mane coffee bundle check it out
plus you will also receive an additional
20% off at checkout
so claim this deal you must go to four
sig Matic
come / Tim for sig Matic that's fo you
are SI g m8 IC dot-com / Tim this offer
is only for you my dear podcast
listeners and is not available on their
regular website so go to for sig Matic
dot-com / Tim and get yourself some
awesome and delicious lion's mane coffee
and check out their other stuff they've
got a whole spectrum of products that I
use on the regular full discount applied
at check out
you
[Applause]
you